[Music]
does anyone here feel that they have
been having more vivid dreams or more
bad dreams more vivid yeah never
remember any single dream in mind I've
been having more dreams mine's just more
powerful if I'm tired like you know when
you go to sleep really tired and you
have the craziest dreams where you don't
even know if it's a real dream or not do
you ever have a dream you wanna do so
much it's real two days ago I woke up
and I had a boner through my fly what my
dick was touching my blanket why's my
dick that I usually would sleep with
underwear on so like - you're [ __ ]
yes my question was did you ever have a
dream and then you wake up and then you
have boners through your fly boys the
dream about I don't remember your back
why can't you be a news anchor asking
questions and then words like you know
what this is fascinating I'm gonna ask
this question later on Jay can you
[Laughter]
imagine if we had the budget where all
of us went out and we were able to
interview people and do all that [ __ ]
I want Bart to be interviewing Patrick
Stewart and you're like Patrick Stewart
you ever had a butter through your fly
you know I just want to see what this
monkey says nobody's ever asked these
kinds of questions
so my boners always on top of my blanket
he talks that way about his boner I
think I nailed the accent Google
searches have gone up 200 percent for
the phrase why do I keep having weird
dreams whoa 190 percent increase and
users asking why do I keep having bad
dream maybe people are just sleeping
more now where people are so
sleep-deprived before their just leave
yeah I barely had dreams because I was
sleep-deprived yeah I do feel like if I
Slee
longer because I need people say the
last hour of your sleep is when you have
the most vivid dream right so if I sleep
longer I have crazier dreams we do more
so much more bored than I think they
remember that they had dreams true
because most of us are waking up and
panicking and getting to work but you
know it's crazy increased by 200 wait
2,450 percents in searches for why am I
dreaming about my ex whoa yeah mm
because now they have time to
psychologically let go of things that
they did or the opposite right they have
time to reflect and they're like [ __ ] I
miss this person could be they say
dreaming of your ex could be
metaphorically dreaming about times gone
by and sadness about losing those times
if you feel your ex abandoned you this
can be around self-acceptance not being
cared for or feeling left out and not
include it if you were dominated in the
relationship it can be a reminder to
take your power back and affirm your own
sense of strength well [ __ ] this guy
what does he know what if I want to be
dominated and my relationship I had a
dream about a chimpanzee what are you
guys doing was your ex we're just
chillin delive are your ex we were in
the jungle was his boner through his fly
[ __ ] fly right here [ __ ] fly on
the money people say that Howard Stern
is the greatest interviewer I think that
it's bark wanna [ __ ] you because I got
the magic fly touch look it's on my
finger fly whispered a huge why do you
want to do this I will fly whisperer
a six hundred percent increase in
searches was for what does it mean when
you dream about falling oh yeah
sometimes I like them only the kind when
you're like about to fall asleep and
you're like [ __ ] Oh happen yeah hate
those
stop it if anyone ever dream of the ones
where you just keep falling forever or
not oh no my not fall like as soon as I
fall I wake up like it's like it's like
a quick jolt I fall for a long time too
and right when I'm about to make impact
I wake up I have had a dream once where
I did make impact and I'm just laying
there in the floor and I'm like okay I
think I died I'm good
your dreams are sad your dreams are
always sad why so sad there was this one
time where I dreamt of but no I don't
have a good one do you ever wake up with
your [ __ ] free to fly it's hitting the
blanket like anyway he's so fair see he
doesn't care about the gender that's why
he's the greatest interview of all time
Howard Stern is is like going so as
notices like how come I've never asked
this question first off you have to wear
one of those underwears where the dick
hole can open which girls wear I know
you wear guy underwear sometimes I
underwear with a shot she's got to have
a big enough [ __ ] lip that can dangle
outside of that this whole thing and
that's not only because you got used and
abused not always no it's just genetics
I'm frightened sometimes okay let's take
it back to the dreaming so dreaming of
losing teeth and dreaming of hair
falling out both have seen a 400%
increase in searches losing teeth I've
had that one before like it just falls
out or like like you're brushing your
teeth and it starts to crumble and
you're just like speeding and you're
like walked off Fogg name your game
Washington no for me I was in brushing
teeth I was just for some reason up in
front of a mirror and then like I just
noticed like my tooth is a little Wiggly
and then just like fell out and then
like more fell out and I was like what
the [ __ ] I heard that that was meaning
you're losing control of something you
ever get one where a guy just brain him
he pulls out a gun and shoots you but
you felt like completely safe moments
prior to that I've had something closer
but my mynah last a long time that I was
like this biker gang came after me a
biker gang
yeah and then like I started hitting
them back and then they were starting to
they would bleed orange
[ __ ] beer you got the shadow riders
coming after Saturday you ever have one
where you're asleep but you wake up and
you don't wake up you're floating over
your body and then you see a shadow man
trying to get inside the body while you
while you're panic know a couple months
every couple months they want us to do
grocery stories on here too is pretty
scary dude most of my dreams are like
really happy and like just weird and
crazy but none of them are really bad
like nightmares I've only had two I
think two dreams in my life where I wake
up because I'm laughing so hard oh I
like those and then I try to explain
what the dream was but as I'm seeing it
in this real world it's like so not
funny not that that's a great dog never
had that happen really no my typical
dream is like I have a penis on my nose
I'm climbing like Grand Canyon like
going going with my nose oh you should
make a face mask underwear that's my
they're all crazy like that I told you
guys this one but I always dream that
I'm running on all fours like one girl
yeah I don't know why but in my dream
I'm always like like I have to like run
after someone or someone's chasing me
but I'm running for some reason and I
always have this thought of like I can
do this faster if I want all like I need
my hands to help are you going faster
than I am one with the earth yeah
feeling it do you guys ever fly outside
your body energy yep no no I don't fly
in my body but never outside never
outside to really see your body and then
you go even look all over the place yeah
oh I've seen myself fall backwards at
McDonald's and then as soon as I hit the
floor my body she got I mean my spirit
went out and I saw myself and McDonald's
McDonald's yeah I was at McDonald's
eating a hamburger and I felt better
life not in a dream not really my dream
what oh wait you were in McDonald's in
real life though and then you fell
asleep in town I was eating a hamburger
at McDonalds I took a bite and I looked
back because Jesus was walking behind me
and I was like what the [ __ ] Jesus and I
fell backwards and as soon as I fell
back it made impact my spirit lifted up
and everyone was like surrounding my
body like oh [ __ ]
is he okay is he okay and I'm like oh
how do I get back in yeah I know what
that means what you're gonna die when
Jesus comes go inside the McDonald's and
eat have to just get drive-thru now cuz
it was just mcdonald and i was gonna
take a bite and I fell backwards and I
know how much you enjoy the dining
experience inside the from now on you
just gotta drive okay well don't look
back if I see a guy that looks like
Jesus
well these there's guys who look like
Jesus all tonight especially in LA as
homeless people exactly the one that
[ __ ] hate are the ones where you like
nudity
like you're peeing or taking a [ __ ] in
your dream and then you wake up mid [ __ ]
and you're like what I just said you're
really sure your bed no I've never lied
my bed I wake up you're like did I just
do it and you
I checked though I check every time I'm
on no for me I've never felt this shitty
one but I have felt the peeing one and
you go yourself it has happened where I
do wake up and it is like I actually did
pee but that hasn't happened in like
forever
was your [ __ ] through your fly I
invented a chicken recipe [ __ ] what what
does it do for you if somebody says yes
it's satisfying it's kind of like oh we
relate yeah dick hole brothers I guess I
invented a chicken recipe in my dream
and I made it real in real life that's a
bomb-ass chick yeah like the brown sugar
chicken the grilled chicken right I
would have never [ __ ] thought of that
in real life so I made that taste and I
said this is just delicious I woke up in
the middle of the night went to the
[ __ ] kitchen and start mixing it up
and grilling
the only guy who would actually do that
most people just go ahead a crazy dream
I'm a chicken I think it leaves you with
that like you need to fulfill it you
crazy
find out what it was like gasps I forgot
the opposite way you know sometimes
people talk about they come they have a
really good dream and they're like that
could be a movie you wake up you write
it down I've done that before when I
wake up I write it down and then I go
back to sleep I wake up the next morning
I'm like this is [ __ ] terrible write
this salad I do that with my notes I
wake up write my note go to bed and his
[ __ ] gobbledygook you know sick da
Vinci and they were all bad oh good what
the difference is his [ __ ] was good the
difference is he was Leonardo DaVinci
yeah he was like inventing helicopters
you see in the middle of sleep wait wait
he dreamt up all his inventions a lot of
them do you realize that sleep takes up
most of your life this one hassle
culture people say he figured out a way
to like sleep minimal and then wake up
and then you know just work on a [ __ ]
but he was a workaholic but I'm sure
like 90 something percent of the things
that he created to suck oh yeah yes
flying machines sucked ass never worked
yeah it's like a bicycle from my canteen
he didn't sleep so and obviously Mona
Lisa wherever she ate the hottest girl
know if he was alive today he would have
been like oh I was so wrong he was like
she's a five yeah
[Music]
[Music]